[Music]
collections of well-defined and distinct
objects are referred to as sets these
objects that form a part of the set are
referred to as elements sets are used by
experts for economic analysis and it's
also used widely in programming all of
us use it in our daily lives as well we
use sets when we select a set of songs
for a playlist we also use sets to
create a team of people and we also use
it to arrange utensils in a kitchen as
there are so many applications we should
definitely know more about sets in this
course we will look at the different
types of sets and the ways in which sets
can be written yes these are the
different types so many of them out of
all these we will study subsets in
extreme detail and we will also see how
to convert sets from one form to another
after these concepts are covered we will
move on to operation on sets and how
Venn diagrams can be used to understand
sets better happy learning and do
subscribe to our channel for more
awesome content
[Music]